the scariest time for us developers has  to be job interviews  the second scariest is when we deploy a  new version of our code to production  but cloud run can take the fear out of  deployments  when i deploy a new version of any of my  cloud run services i send only 10 of  traffic to it the other 90  stay on the previous version  i wait for a day to see if my users or  logs report any problems if there is a  problem i turn the new version back down  to zero percent and fix it  if not i increase the percentage  gradually until the new version is at  one hundred percent  this is called a canary release i like  this approach because if there is a  problem i will learn about it before  most of my users do  even with the best of testing we  developers won't catch all corner cases  or oddball browser behavior out there  use cloudrun to take the fear out of  your deployments